and moving on to Ukraine now the true
scale of the flood disaster in southern
Ukraine is still unclear but one Russian
official in the region is now reporting
five fatalities and Ukraine's president
vlodimir zielinski visited the Harrison
region this morning inspecting damage
from the flooding flooding that is now
ravaging that area for a third straight
day Deborah patta has more
hurry up
on her son they Wade through the Deluge
clutching their possessions using
whatever they can to stay afloat
while stranded animals gather on what
little high ground they can find
fresh drinking water is flown in by
drones to desperate residents and
soldiers and volunteers worked
tirelessly to evacuate those trapped by
Rising Waters
pulling them through windows or out of
the murky depths and carrying the frail
and elderly to safety
but danger is always close says Katarina
as a Russian shell lands nearby this may
be a disaster area but it is still a war
zone where despite Russia's Retreat from
her son City last year the bombardment
has not lit up
everywhere anger is close to the surface
Putin must burn in hell this woman
curses adding they couldn't finish us
off now they're trying to drown us
even with a catastrophe of this
magnitude the fighting rages on with
incremental Ukrainian gains being made
keep claims on the Eastern Front yeah
their troops are seen advancing on
Russian positions around the ruined city
of bakmut currently held by Kremlin
forces and the scene of some of the
bloodiest fighting of this conflict
and concern is mounting for those
trapped by floods in russian-controlled
areas president zielinski has called for
an urgent International Rescue effort
Vlad
Deborah patta in Ukraine for us thank
you